I'm gonna tell you everything you need
to know about the American Press I'm
going to tell you every single thing
that you need to know about the
establishment media in two headlines
both from The New York Times this one
October 10 2022.
Biden Storyteller in Chief
spins Yarns that often unravel
President Biden has been unable to break
himself of the habit of embellishing
narratives to weave a political identity
oh shucks
this other headline November 1st 2020
also the New York Times
dishonesty has defined the Trump
presidency the consequences could be
lasting whether president Trump wins or
loses on November 3rd the very concept
of public trust in an established set of
facts necessary for the operation of a
Democratic Society has been eroded
foreign
s are talking about the exact same thing
not just similar things not just things
that kind of resemble each other a
little bit
exactly the same thing both stories are
about the president saying things that
are not true
in the case of Biden it's kind of cute
you know it's it's folksiness veering
into folklore as the alternate online
headline of this article put it in the
case of trump it's an existential threat
to the nation it's the erosion of our
Democratic Society
this is not an isolated case this is not
an exceptional example this is how the
entire establishment media work all the
time it's not just that they get stories
wrong often intentionally
it's that the entire framing of every
story is designed to help the libs and
hurt conservatives
they like Biden aren't folksy yarn
spinning storytellers
they are paid and Powerful liars and
propagandists and they've done
infinitely more to erode the operation
of our Democratic Society than have
Donald Trump and all the other
conservative voices put together I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Auto pump who
says I appreciate Tulsa gabbard choosing
to leave the Democrat Party but a little
bit of me wonders what took so long it
was pretty clear all the way back in the
ancient history of 2020 when she was
running for president as a Democrat that
the party was going down this path yeah
that's true obviously we we all know
that or at least the majority of
listeners to this podcast who are
probably not Ardent partisan Democrats
uh yes we've all known that for a long
time but I'm not going to knock Tulsi
yeah she should have known it in 2020
she should have known in 2016 she okay
fine she knows it now that's good enough
for me I'm glad that she is seeing the
light a lot other people are seeing the
light that's a wonderful thing she's
thinking for herself and we need to
think for ourselves do for ourselves
when you want to fix your car for
yourself you got to check out RockAuto
right now go to rockauto.com enter
Knowles in there how did you hear about
us box I absolutely adore Rock Auto I
adore them because they've been with
this show basically since day one for
years and years and years now two I Love
Rock Auto because they don't make me
feel like a big dummy when I need Auto
Parts okay listen I'm not exactly the
handiest guy in the world okay I don't
know everything about every type of make
and model of course RockAuto makes it so
so easy and they always give you
reliably the lowest prices chain stores
have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers rockauto.com's prices
are the same for everybody no gimmicks
no login on Tuesday and you get this
price and none of that stuff they've
been serving Auto Parts customers online
for 20 years you go to rockauto.com shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
Manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and Brake
Parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
your daily driver you can get everything
that you need with just a few easy
clicks delivered right to your door go
to rockauto.com right now enter Knowles
in there how did you hear about this box
so they know that we sent you that is
rockauto.com
Alex Jones has just been ordered to pay
a lot of money
to the parents of victims of the Sandy
Hook shooting
because he went on the air and said that
the Sandy Hook shooting wasn't real that
it was a false flag it didn't really
happen and he he
spun a yarn you might say about what
what that shooting really was
Alex Jones because he got that story
wrong on the air it now has to pay
according to a court in Connecticut
more than 950 million dollars
to the families of eight victims of the
Sandy Hook shooting
that is in addition to a ruling from a
separate jury in Texas ordering Jones to
pay 4.1 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 45.2 million dollars in
punitive damages so we are now talking
about roughly
one billion dollars that Alex Jones a
radio host known for his Hyperbole and
kind of eccentric bizarre really out
there kind of implausible take sometimes
a man who rips off his shirt screaming
about the freaking frogs going gay that
guy because he got a story wrong on the
air has to pay a billion dollars
that's a lot of money for getting
something wrong on the radio don't you
think
but Michael he got it really wrong yeah
okay but Michael it was awful what he
said sure Michael it was really really
awful yeah okay fine I'm not I'm not
arguing I'm not I'm not disputing that
billion dollars for getting something
wrong in the radio
has has there ever been a radio host
ever who has not gotten something wrong
on the radio
even uh well probably me I'm not sure
that I've ever gotten a single thing no
maybe maybe even I have gotten some
things wrong but Michael it wasn't okay
yeah let's say that Alex Jones said the
he got it as wrong as terrible it was
the worst reporting of any story ever in
the whole history of the world billion
dollars for getting that wrong
as far as I know Alex Jones hasn't
killed anybody
his
storytelling on the radio
didn't get anybody killed either
what kind of damages
are we going to see paid out by the
people who who lied about the covet
vaccines and who got the covid vaccines
wrong and who said that not only would
they protect you from getting the virus
and and transmitting the virus but that
they would actually they were totally
safe totally effective and now a bunch
of kids are dead because of heart
problems that even the CDC now admits
the vaccines cause very serious heart
problems and the ones that don't cause
cause heart problems cause blood clots
do those people have to pay any damages
because that wasn't just some Texas
radio host who got that story wrong that
was the entire establishment media and
all of our elected officials certainly
on the Democrat side
and the president of the United States
said these are totally fine these are
totally safe but I'm actually going to
mandate that you get these get these
shots even though kids are at very very
low risk from the virus and oh yeah okay
if you get heart problems and you die
oopsie Daisy I'm gonna deny that at
first and then I'm going to admit that
that happened but say it's not a big
deal
are they going to have what what are
they gonna pay I don't think they're
going to pay a billion dollars or a
million dollars or one dollar I don't
think they're going to pay Jack diddly
squat
and so I don't call call me kallus but I
just
I just think that paying a billion
dollars out
for getting something wrong on the radio
when you're a right winger even an
eccentric right-winger
seems a little bit crazy when the left
that lies about everything that lies in
a much more persuasive and serious way
about much more
urgent matters for the vast majority of
people they don't ever pay a price at
all
see that seems wrong to me that seems
kind of backwards to me
I think they ought to pay I think the
billion dollars that Alex Jones is
supposed to pay I think we need at least
a 100 a 1 000 a 100 000 times that
payout from the libs who lie constantly
in much more consequential wise
on that vaccine Point by the way
Dr Paul Offutt is a voting member of the
FDA panel that approves the vaccines
he's just blowing the whistle now on the
oversight or lack thereof for the
vaccine approval process
do the benefits of this vaccine outweigh
the rest I didn't see the benefits we
really need much better data I think
before we move forward on this and I can
only hope that it's coming because I
feel very strongly about my no vote
there in fact the only reason I voted no
was because hell no was not a choice and
it just um
surprised me that we were willing to go
forward with this with such scant
evidence of benefit I think the phrase
that I used was uncomfortably scant so
you just sort of felt like the fix was
in a little bit here maybe that's not
the right phrase but it was something
that they wanted and
I felt like we were being led here and
with that with with a a critical lack of
information right now they're saying
that we should trust Mouse data and I
don't think that should ever be true I I
don't think you should ever ask tens of
millions of people to get a vaccine
based on mass data and there's no public
data on that yet what's more for these
fall booster shots the FDA is not
Consulting with Dr offit and the rest of
the independent vaccine advisory
committee
and there you have it there you have it
we've known this from the very beginning
and actually the people who were talking
about this at the very beginning of the
coveted vaccines we were all called
conspiracy theorists and cougs and
anti-science turns out we were
completely right
we were completely right
and so you talk about even someone like
Alex Jones who is an Entertainer on the
radio and sure he's gotten something
super duper wrong sure yeah of course
his record overall on on every story
he's ever talked about including the gay
frogs by the way which he was completely
right about he was actually modest about
because the water in the in the water in
Connecticut I'm sorry the chemicals in
the water in the in Connecticut we're
turning the frogs hermaphroditic not gay
they were transiting them not not
turning them gay
Alex Jones's overall record is
definitely better than CNN's record
definitely better than the Washington
Post record
definitely better than New York Times
Record no question there's no question
about that
I don't see any of them paying out a
billion dollars
and and very you might say well their
lies are not as hurtful as Alex Jones's
I don't know to measure hurtfulness for
me please I can tell you their lies are
much more consequential kids are dead
because of their lies
kids are dead of myocarditis because of
their lives
okay and a lot and a lot of other
problems too so I just I just don't buy
that stuff and when they're not
when they're not uh putting the fix in
as Dr often is saying when they are not
sacrificing
safety and caution and prudence and
self-government for a little extra
profit and a little more political
control what are they doing when they're
when they're not jabbing the kids full
of shots that in most cases they really
there's no argument that they need them
at all they are transiting the kids and
and we've been
blowing the whistle on this for a long
time
and uh now we've got some data here that
actually show the consequences of a
years-long campaign to trans the kids
you've got a 582 percent increase
in quote gender non-conforming kids in
one of the largest counties in one of
the most important states in the country
Montgomery County Schools
this is the largest county in Maryland
Maryland uh is obviously right there by
the Beltway you know right there at the
very heart of our nation's capital
Montgomery County schools are reporting
a 582 increase in gender non-conforming
students in two years pretty wild you
can see this report here from The Daily
Caller
they've gathered this data this is a
near Sevenfold increase from 2019 to
2022.
what are the odds
what are the odds how do you explain
that
well could be
it could be that there's something in
the water I guess could be it could be
that this is a social contagion that is
spreading which is obviously what it is
either way though this really blows up
the Democrats narrative because the the
Democrats on the in the libs broadly on
the sexual Revolution have for years
said look people are born this way
sexual orientation is immutable it's
from birth who would choose this you
can't have any conversion therapy social
forces have no effect on your sexual
orientation
well if that's the case then how is this
increasing so much
if you're just then it has to be
biological there's got to be some kind
of chromosomal issue right there's got
to be something in the womb
except that babies aren't babies in the
womb so that kind of that kind of messes
up their narrative there as well so it
messes up their abortion narrative it
messes up their gay rights narrative now
it's messing up the transgender
narrative 582 percent increase why is
that do you think it might have
something to do with the fact that
educators are teaching little kids all
the way down to kindergarten that boys
can be girls and girls could be boys no
that's crazy that's a crazy conspiracy
theory that's not happening and it is
happening and it's good by the way and
but it's not transiting the kids it's
not causing anyone to question their sex
or gender or change it except it is it's
a 582 increase except that's a crazy
conspiracy theory except it's happening
and it's true are you dizzy yet I I
can't it's very hard to track
any of that
Democrats success
in trancing the kids Democrats success
in their political agenda has undermined
a lot of their narratives their
narratives unborn this way their
narratives on uh sex and gender are
totally different sex and gender are the
same
homosexual rights is that they're boys
and they're girls and some boys like
boys and some girls like girls but then
their narrative on transgenderism is
that actually there's no such thing as
girls and boys and boys can be girls and
girls can be boys none of the narratives
make sense okay
it's just power and and I guess this
this takes me back to Alex Jones it
takes me back to the the New York Times
right Joe Biden lies that's so cute and
great and wonderful Donald Trump lies
it's going to completely destroy the
Republic
the arguments don't matter the
narratives don't matter the the
arguments don't matter the facts really
don't matter to them it's all framing
it's all narrative and it's why I I
can't you know stand up on the rooftops
and condemn Alex Jones or any of the
other uh celebrities
that the left turns on because they in
any way question the right wing
narrative I haven't I haven't talked
about Kanye's tweet you know Kanye sends
some fairly eccentric tweets every now
and again and I haven't made a big deal
about it even though the left is
insisting you have to disavow Khan yeah
you always have to disavow Kanye what
Kanye said
and and what Kanye is being accused of
is absolutely nothing compared to the
things that ilhan Omar has said that
Louis Farrakhan has said that Barack
Obama's former Pastor said and Barack
Obama's former pastor with connections
to all that that same kind of movement
and connections to Farrakhan and all the
rest of it and that all gets completely
written off Obama actually smiles next
to Louis Farrakhan and and celebrities
from Hollywood take pictures next to
Louis Farrakhan and Al sharp and that's
all completely fine then Kanye West says
something that is one one thousandth as
harsh and severe and bigoted as any of
those people and we're told we have to
disavow this guy like it has absolutely
nothing to do with Kanye West's comments
it has everything to do with the fact
that Kanye West now is more right-wing
in many of his views he's pro-life he's
pro-family he's pro-public Christianity
and so that's why they go after him it
has nothing to do with the the facts
that they're pretending to go after him
for they're going after Alex Jones not
because he got the Sandy Hook story
wrong that has nothing to do with it
they're going after Alex Jones because
they hate Alex Jones because Alex Jones
is right wing and he's popular and so
they're they've been de-platforming that
guy censoring that guy for years and
they found this one issue which is a
really good issue to go after him for
and they're making him pay a billion
dollars for getting a story wrong on the
air that's what it's about and that's
why I can't it's not I have no desire to
defend any of these comments or any of
these reports or stories or anything in
the abstract it's just that the game is
so obviously rigged read the New York
time headlines it's so disingenuous it's
in such bad faith that I see absolutely
no obligation
to entertain it and actually I think
it's probably wrong to entertain their
game and play their game because it
further ensconces them in power and it's
not in any way in good faith
and because they're trancing the kids
and that's bad it's really weird and bad
to trans the kids speaking of Democrats
weird obsession with our children
Kamala Harris is
claiming your children hide your kids
hide your wife especially hide your kids
from Kamala Harris she's claiming them
as her own
I mean truly when you you know when you
see our kids and I truly believe that
they are our children they are the
children of our country of our
communities
I I mean our future is really bright if
we if we prioritize them and therefore
prioritize the climate crisis and the
need to address it
our children our kids and they are our
kids and they're Ark and they're my kids
and they're mine and so Kamala Harris is
insinuating here very heavily is that
she has a right to dictate how your kids
are raised and it's the same thing that
Hillary Clinton's been saying for a long
time when she uses the phrase it takes a
village what she's really saying is I
have the right to raise your kids it's
the same thing when the Oba when the
Biden rather while that was a Freudian
slip when the Biden Administration says
that parents who are questioning uh the
kind of nonsense their kids are being
taught in schools that they're akin to
domestic terrorists that's what they're
saying they're saying we have a right to
raise your kids when you have left-wing
activists
saying we're going to go in and take
queer children whatever that means out
of their families and away from their
homes and put them into queer homes you
remember that story from a couple of
weeks ago all this kind of stuff when
the when the school guidance counselors
are hiding the fact from parents that
children are identifying as transgender
and all the rest of it in some cases
even recommending that they go on
different
sex-changing drugs I mean all what all
of this is about is parents who have no
right to raise your kids
we have the we the liberal establishment
have the right to do everything
and there's three takes here
there's the lib take
which is
the children are our children
collectively we're gonna do what we want
to do and by hour by the way they mean
the liberal oligarchy that runs the
country
then there's the libertarian take which
is the state has no right to raise our
children or my children have nothing to
do with the state my children are mine
and that's that and then there's the
conservative take
which is actually kind of a blend of the
liberal take and the libertarian take
because while the conservative take says
the families have a particular claim to
our own children
it also acknowledges the social
realities and the political realities
that liberal take takes into account
which is that we live in a society and
actually it really does take a village
to raise a child because children are
not just formed in a some Silo by their
mother and their father and maybe their
brother in a home but they're they're
they are educated they are brought up by
the whole of society by their neighbors
by their cousins by the environment in
which they live by the schools that they
go to by the businesses that they
frequent by Good Old Mr McGillicuddy
down at the butcher shop and by the
churches that they go to and by what
their society celebrates and exalts and
that's all part of it okay statecraft
really is soulcraft is what the
conservatives understand and so
I I think the conservative view is the
best of all worlds because it protects
the rights of parents to raise our kids
but it it also is not completely
impotent like the libertarian view it's
not just it's not completely giving up
the the political power that sometimes
the people give us which is the essence
of self-government
that the conservative view says yeah we
have to protect the rights of families
to raise kids and we need to protect the
political environment so that these poor
kids aren't preyed on and perverted all
the time we got to kick the drag queens
out of the schools and we got to kick
these weirdos out these guidance
counselors who are trying to trans the
kids and we got to pass laws against
abortion so that we can protect other
kids and we've got to encourage a
society that wants to do good stuff and
avoid bad stuff instead of what we have
today which is the complete inversion of
that that we have a political right and
obligation to create a good flourishing
Society because that's what's going to
raise kids because our kids actually are
a collective responsibility in the sense
that the kids are the future of the
country and this country is mine as much
as it is yours and I want to live in a
good country
I don't think there's anything crazy
about that I think that's the same
rational conservative point of view you
know back in June of 2020 Candace Owens
took to social media to question the
narrative about George Floyd
she took a barrage of insults as a
result
celebrities insulted her GoFundMe
de-platformed her as the attacks ramped
up daily wire plus gave her a platform
to speak out without fear of being
silenced and supported her investigation
into black lives matter
that organization raised 80 million
dollars through fundraising but no one
ever asked where the money went
until right now Candace Owens reveals
the truth in her new documentary the
greatest lie ever sold now streaming
exclusively on daily wire plus because
of our members we are able to create a
thriving alternative platform and pursue
the truth wherever it leads daily wire
Plus members defeated the vaccine
mandates in the Supreme Court DIY Plus
members helped us uncover the Loudoun
County sexual assault cover-up
daily wire Plus members empowered Matt
Walsh to expose explose expose
Vanderbilt's practice of mutilating
children in the name of gender affirming
care and just over the weekend the
layour Plus members caused PayPal to
backtrack on its orwellian fines for
misinformation remember we are speaking
for you and fighting for your beliefs
too free speech is our weapon here and
with the left's iron grip on culture in
the mainstream media someone had to step
up and fill that void
so you go go check out that movie it's a
great movie now
speaking of
our liberal establishment
speaking of Kamala Harris I think Kamala
Harris is probably the strongest
argument uh for all of us to keep Joe
Biden in power as long as possible you
know we would all want to impeach Joe
Biden except for Kamala whenever I hear
Kamala speak I say Joe
we're pulling for you Joe come on Stick
Around please and and that's damning
with faint praise because Joe Biden just
looks so weak he just looks like such a
failure you know he has been claiming
for months now that the United States
it's not in a recession we're not headed
for a recession now you'll notice he's
starting to shift his language even
ahead of the midterms and he's saying
look yeah it's not don't worry about
recession maybe just maybe just a little
tiny recession
should the American people prepare for a
recession no look they've been saying
this now how every every six months they
say this every six months they look down
the next six months and see what's going
to happen it hadn't happened yet it
hadn't there there has there is no
there's no guarantee that they're going
to be I don't think there will be a
recession if it is it'll be a very
slight recession that is we'll move down
slightly
so just for the record we are currently
in a recession and no politically
correct leftist orwellian wordsmithing
is going to change that we are in a
recession the definition of a recession
is two consecutive quarters of negative
GDP growth that is what the economists
agree is the meaning of a recession
that's what Biden's economists said is
the meaning of a recession before for
political convenience they tried to
change their opinion when we were in a
recession but that's what it is so we
are in a recession but even
going along with Joe's live for a second
oh I'm sorry just his folksy yarn
spinning story tales or whatever uh even
going along with his lies for a second
notice the shift even in the interview
we're not headed for a recession
and and when we are it'll be a small
recession
we're not transiting the kids and it's
good that we are
we're not the border is not open and
it's great that we're welcoming all
these people in
we're not we're not at war with Russia
and we need to stand firm in the war
with Russia
we're not in a recession and it's just a
slight recession you know if Joe Biden
is saying
it okay maybe now we're headed for a
slight recession we we're headed for the
Great Depression I don't mean to laugh
about it but you're going to laugh or
cry that's what he's that's what he's
saying
that's bad that is really bad if the
president of the United States is
admitting this before the midterm
elections
you know
I hope you have a diversified portfolio
that's what that's all I'm saying and I
hope you're stuck stocking up on food
and gas for the winter because clearly
Joe Biden is trying to manage
expectations here and he at least is
anticipating that things are going to
get very very bad
speaking of our financial system some
good news coming out of South Carolina
South Carolina State Treasurer Curtis
Loftus has announced that he will pull
the state's remaining 200 million
dollars in upholdings in asset
management company BlackRock
by the end of the year so this has been
a movement it's been really popularized
by my friend Vivek ramaswamy
uh but it's it's gone around to all of
these State treasurers because
you've got three big asset management
companies that are basically controlling
the marketplace BlackRock Vanguard and
State Street and what these companies
are doing is they're using their intense
trillions and trillions of dollars of
Leverage to force the companies under
their control to start pushing wokeness
I I first really got what got woke to
this myself when I heard that Cracker
Barrel was going to be offering a
vegetarian sausage and I said whoa whoa
whoa whoa
not one vegetarian has ever walked into
a Cracker Barrel
not one not once that has never happened
so if Cracker Barrel is offering
vegetarian sausage it is not because of
a demand of the customers is because
someone is putting a gun to their head
and saying offer the vegetarian sausage
and then I looked I said who are the
major investors in
in Cracker Barrel and of course it's
these guys it's people like Black Rock
and States reading Vanguard so I said
okay they're pushing it what are they
pushing they're pushing the ESG agenda
environment environmental social
governance policies which just means
push leftism in in the companies and
then the companies wanting to keep their
investors happy say okay fine how are
the asset managers able to do that
where did they get their money from well
in many cases they get their money from
State pensions they get their money from
these huge financial institutions
including government institutions
including the states so if you want to
really strike a blow at wokeness yeah
hold some rallies outside that's good
yeah you know have a really good
political campaign social media campaign
have it come up with a good slogan but
really what you got to do is defund the
wokeness how do you defund the wokeness
well you wield that political power that
you get on Happy occasions when you get
a state treasurer in a state to pull
that money out of the companies that are
pushing it and that is actually what is
happening right now you heard similar
announcements from Louisiana we need to
gut these companies a lot of politics
comes down to Cold Hard Cash okay you
know politics is made up of a lot of BS
there's a lot of BS posturing and lying
and slogeneering and propaganda I mean
that's just all Biden does right he's
just a a sort of empty suit empty-headed
parrot of of his party's propaganda and
he blows where the wind wind blows well
BS
taught no I'm sorry BS walks I got a
little confused there first I had a
Biden moment BS walks and money talks
and so this is a great use of state
power
again you know there are three views on
this the liberal view is use the use the
political powers in any capricious
arbitrary way to push your own radical
agenda the libertarian view is that
politics needs to remain totally neutral
and we should never push our substantive
views ever into the public and it's all
just a complete free Marketplace of
ideas and everything's totally neutral
and then there's the conservative view
which is no we actually need to wield
our political power to have a good
country and not have a bad country and
the conservative view I think melds the
best parts or the best observations of
the liberal View and the libertarian
view
because it says no politics actually is
substantive it's a moral playground you
inevitably have to legislate morality
that's just what the law is and so
instead of the libs who want to advance
evil and suppress good we're going to do
the opposite of that but it also
respects the views of the Libertarians
which is that people have a right to a
return on their investment and that
markets should not be uh just completely
destroyed in order to manipulate them
for political ends and we shouldn't just
completely uh disregard our fiduciary
responsibility to shareholders and so
what these State treasurers are saying
this is what Curtis Loftus the South
Carolina State Treasurer is saying and
Louisiana and other GOP treasurers
around the country they're saying you
BlackRock you State Street you Vanguard
are are betraying your fiduciary
responsibilities to your shareholders
because you're not putting profits
first you're not maximizing profits to
your shareholders you are actually
damaging profits to push this woke
agenda
so what you're actually doing is when
you force Cracker Barrel to to have the
vegetarian sausage which again I don't I
don't have a transcript of a phone call
or anything where BlackRock calls up
Cracker Barrel and says push the veggie
sausage but it's hard to figure out any
other reason they have the veggie
sausage what that what they're actually
doing is damaging profits because not
one person ever will order the veggie
sausage at Cracker Barrel and so the
conservative View at least right now the
conservative tactic on this is melding
the kind of best versions of the liberal
View and the libertarian view and by the
way it's working
it's working to attack these soulless
asset managers I say soulless BlackRock
right now
BlackRock right now has been referring
to the potential Chinese invasion of
Taiwan
as a reunification
they said BlackRock
uh has been
has quote highlighted for the past year
the investment risk should China China
take steps to accelerate reunification
with Taiwan so first of all they're
referring to a military Invasion as
reunification
right they're already accepting the
claim that Taiwan belongs to China
which is something that the United
States has certainly not admitted
we haven't conceded that that's not the
foreign policy of the United States we
we have accepted something called The
One China policy which is very vague but
it does not deny that Taiwan has its own
rights as Sovereign political entities
at least a semi-sovereign political
entity
but then the other thing that
blackrock's doing here is they're just
taking it as a fatal company that that
Taiwan is going to become fully part of
China and so they're saying it's going
to accelerate this trend
why are they doing that because they're
making a bet on China
right they're saying China's a serious
country China's economy is going in the
right direction China's Society is on a
stronger track than American society is
and so these guys are taking the side of
China and I just see no reason to
Outsource our political
power like that
to Blackrock or State Street or Vanguard
or anyone like that our Elite
are betraying our country our there is
always going to be an elite
so while I am very sympathetic to the
populists I guess I'm on the side of the
populists I'm on the side of the people
I'd rather be governed by the first
hundred people in the Boston phone book
than by The Faculty of Harvard College
as William F Buckley Jr said while I'm
I'm strongly on the side of the people
here and the battle between liberalism
and democracy I'm on the side of
democracy
but we have to acknowledge there is an
elite and the problem that we're facing
right now is not that there is an elite
there is always an elite the problem
that we're facing right now is that the
elite is very very bad
our Elite in this country
and there's always going to be one our
Elite
are supposed to put the common good of
the American people before their own
selfish interests and they're not doing
that
Kanye West just made a very very good
point
not not not the point that not the thing
that everyone's talking about with Kanye
that as I said I just see no reason
really to address it because I think the
whole debate has become so disingenuous
and it's being pushed in very bad faith
by people who have said and who have
applauded statements far more egregious
than what Kanye West said but by people
like Louis Farrakhan and others
but Kanye West made
a different
good point this was on the Kardashians
and you using the Kardashians as a
symbol
of how the elite ought to behave take a
listen you know there's some
responsibilities that I still feel needs
to be taken by the entire family right
about the way we present ourselves
everything that we do we need to present
ourselves with the highest level of
nobility when we're in a position of
influence like we are we have to say do
we want our children to do this and not
just our children everyone's children
because we're being used as an influence
to everyone's children to sell the
product that gives us that affords us
the houses that we put the 800 million
security guards in front of so knowing
that to whom is given much is required
much is required I also require that
to those who are given lots and lots of
things
there is much that is expected
in terms of your responsibility to your
people this of course this this was the
common understanding of what an elite is
until very very recently
and the left has abandoned that the left
has totally denies the the moral order
and says that they're just going to push
their own interests and their own
selfish interests above all others the
right has kind of abandoned this too
though
the right has largely until very
recently abandoned the language of the
common good of the responsibility of the
elite to their Common Man the the right
embraced an idea that sort of greed is
good and I'm in it for me and just do
whatever you want just for yourself and
you know if you're not in the elite
we'll just you know pull yourself up by
your bootstraps and get a job stupid you
know and and yeah of course we want
people to be self-sufficient we want
them to be able to feed themselves and
be strong on their own but they're
if you are in the elite and you don't
have any acknowledgment of your
responsibility to the society which has
afforded you so much
then you can't have a country and you
can't have a society because it's just
so Preposterous to believe that you
individually
are 100 entirely responsible for your
success in life that is not possible the
libs want to pretend that you're zero
percent responsible for your success in
life which is absurd but it's also
absurd to say that you're 100
responsible for your success in life you
have been given many blessings your very
life is a Grace and a blessing okay and
some people are born to a mother and
father who love each other in marriage
that's a great privilege some people are
born in nice neighborhoods some people
are born with a little bit of money some
people are born with privileges
everybody is born with some kind of a
privilege right and some are given a
greater abundance of privileges than
others and there's there's nothing
liberal or leftist about admitting that
that's just called reality and it's
actually a deeply conservative point of
view and that's the point of view that
Kanye West is expressing in that in in
that interview
the idea of a pure meritocracy is not a
conservative idea that is a very liberal
idea that pretends that we're all just
individuals completely divorced from
society but that's not true
what we it's again is that you're just
seeing it's the three points of view
there's the liberal view the libertarian
view and the conservative which I think
takes the best observations of the
liberal View and the libertarian view
here but we do have a responsibility
here the idea of a pure meritocracy does
not get rid of the elite that's one of
the biggest lies that we've been told in
recent decades well you know it's very
wrong and and and uh hierarchical and
old-timey and old-fashioned to have an
elite so what we're going to do is we're
gonna have a pure meritocracy and that's
going to get rid of the elite no it's
not going to get rid of the elite it's
going to replace the old waspy Elite
with a new Elite the difference is that
the new Elite feels absolutely no
obligations to help their fellow man
they're not doing any of the
philanthropic good or a much smaller
portion than the old Elite would but we
do have to have a responsibility it gets
right back to that point on raising our
children
yeah families have the primary
responsibility and right for children
but we all have a political interest in
children because it's our society and so
if our kids are all raised to be
transgender Satan worshipers who are you
know screaming and babbling and chopping
off parts of their body we're going to
live in a crappy society and that's your
problem just as much as it's my problem
so so we have a social and political
right and responsibility to make sure
the kids aren't completely screwed up by
the weirdos in the schools who are doing
that now
speaking of
undignified behavior and speaking of the
libs desecrating things really really
disturbing video
a lib was filming herself desecrating a
memorial to Ashley Babbitt Ashley
Babbitt was the right winger who went
into the capitol on January 6th and was
shot to death by a cop
I guess
nobody wants it here
right nobody wants this
thank you
[Music]
foreign
that's what you get
nobody wants your birthday celebrated on
the capital you dumb
you think these cops want to celebrate
your honor you tried to kill them you
[ __ ] you Mickey
I would like to remind you of something
that you may not have even known I think
even certainly the libs don't know this
and even many conservatives don't know
this
the only people who were killed on
January 6th
we're Trump supporters
and and there were some people who you
know they had heart attacks and things
like that so I I don't know that you
really count that as part of January 6th
I mean people have heart attacks every
single day
the only people who died period in
January 6th were Trump supporters and
the only person who was killed in
political violence was a trump supporter
named Ashley Babbitt
the narrative in the media is that the
Trump supporters killed murdered police
officers that didn't happen that was
completely made up and the New York
Times even had to admit that
the narrative in the media is that it
was the Trump supporters who were so
violent threatening everyone's lives
they almost raped and killed AOC that's
what she told us even though AOC was in
a different building
was it wasn't even in the place where
the where the capital right was
happening
the only person who was killed in that
political violence was Ashley Babbitt
and her
the little Memorial there or small
modest little Memorial was just
desecrated mocked derided stomped
property destroyed by the libs
that is the power of this
that is the if anyone
even so much as looked
with a skeptical glance at one of the
many murals of George Floyd that was
constructed
that were constructed after the the BLM
Summer of Love that killed dozens of
people and burned half the country down
that person would be canceled would be
ostracized to be called the worst person
in the world this this lady is applauded
yeah that shows you Ashley Babbitt
it's just so so disingenuous and it's
why it's why I can't it's why I can
never get into the Trump criticism
that's why I can never get old Trump
he's really bad you know you got to hand
it to the left they're right I mean
Trump he's just so
they're not
the left doesn't go after Trump
because
he said Mika brzezinski's ugly or
whatever he tweeted the left doesn't go
after Trump because he had a phone
because some one of his guys had a phone
call with some guy from Russia or I
don't even remember what the story was
or he he Trump called
Ukraine and it it hasn't it's nothing
they find excuses to destroy people who
question their agenda and who threatened
their power that's what the libs do
and so it's why I can't I can't get so
riled up
even let's say Donald Trump says
something terrible let's say Kanye West
says something terrible let's say Alex
Jones says something terrible yeah
they've all said Terrible Things sure oh
sure okay
the left has said many worse things the
left has done many worse things without
any consequences whatsoever and
furthermore
the libs are not going after these guys
because they said those things the left
is already going after those guys and
they use any excuse they can to destroy
them and then the the retaliation for
for whatever they do is so is so
disproportionate you could say Ashley
Babbitt should not have gone into the
capitol on January 6th sure a lot I
think a lot of people would agree with
that okay
did she deserve to be shot and killed
and then have her memorials desecrated
and called all those terrible things do
you really think Alex Jones shouldn't
have said what he said yeah sure of
course it was wrong it was terrible it
was awful it's Immortal you should go to
confession he should he should apologize
okay sure yeah fine
billion dollars
Donald Trump shouldn't have tweeted the
things he tweeted yeah okay should he
have had his should he have been spied
on by the federal government and then
had his home raided and then had his
presidency completely under of course
not it's just so insane it's so
completely ridiculous and disingenuous
and I just think once you see it once
you see Biden lies isn't that cute
Donald Trump lies it's gonna destroy the
whole country we have to get rid of this
guy once you see that at least for me I
can't unsee that and I can't play their
game and I don't think you should either
now speaking of Kanye
I will be discussing Kanye
on the member block with my friend
Spencer claven the rest of the show is
continuing now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]